hello everyone we are playing the uh
Winters DLC for Resident Evil Village
which I'm super excited about it's one
of the only games that I've actually
like finished in full on this channel so
excited to be playing the DLC
um I'm there definitely interested in
Rosa's story and excited to go back to
Castle dimitrisk not sure how long this
whole thing is exactly I think they said
about four hours but today we are just
going to be playing
um the first hour as I do on this
channel I might stream the rest but
let's jump into it I'm super excited
but I had to re-download the whole game
it's been a minute
the following game mode and extra games
have been added third person mode
mercery's additional orders Shadows of
bros is obviously what we're playing
today third person mode can be selected
via oh I guess you can play the shadows
of rose in
in the um third person mode 2 which is
very cool
it's very neat
streetwolf outfit okay let's go start
game and then we're going to bonuses
Shadows of Rose let's do it
a new game
I'm super excited
okay
sorry I'm late it's okay I'm just
enjoying the day
you said you had something important to
tell me
I hope it's not about Chris wanting me
to join his operation because I already
told him that's not happening
see what he puts you in the rest of his
Hound I could cosplay her mad easily
thank you
it is about you she does look deathly
pale though
is that that moment don't worry about
you
how is um
how are things at school
seriously that's what you wanted to talk
to me about that group of Mean Girls
still
hassling yeah
I mean are they still treating me like a
freak hey
look at me you're not a freak
would you remember being a freak
I know I am that's fine that's why I
keep my distance from everybody at
school
so they knew what I really was
so
you don't have any friends that you can
talk to
talk to about what
how hardly even human how I'm some kind
of horrendous monster
that hey it's okay
I hardly ever murder my friends what if
there were a way to get rid of your
powers it's interesting this is like a
it's basically like a superhero take
part one I get rid of them
all right well
I think there's something I need to show
you
you already know about Miranda this is
not starting in a way I expected
researched it obsessively and perform
experiments on human subjects also I
really like both the voice actors so far
exactly what you don't know is that we
recently found some of her research
apparently she discovered a purifying
Crystal that can remove the mutomycy
from its host
purifying Crystal we can get our hands
on one of these we might be able to
weaken or remove your powers entirely
are you kidding me no no but her notes
are incomplete
however I really I don't know who he is
I really like his voice happening
specifically where we can find the rest
of her research let's do it let's find
it where is it uh
in there
what that's a fragment of the mega mice
heat it absorbs and stores memories from
people who pass away in close proximity
including Miranda and everything she
knows
if you enter its Consciousness you might
be able to solve the mystery of the
purifying Crystal wait what do you mean
enter its consciousness
Okay so
you
your
deep connection
will allow you to
explore the information Within
[Music]
it's Rose but not dangerous we're
hearing impressed by him right there
just like such human delivery through
somebody else's memories
you really think this can work I think
it's worth trying
what do you have to lose
how do I even do this
I don't know try
reaching out to it see what happens
only in Resident Evil okay
you just gotta reach out to the weird
goop tank obviously what the hell
oh my God Rose is so weird yeah it's
like she sees things that aren't there
[Music]
something just moves on her hand
shut up actually pretty bold of her to
go to school to be honest
I respect that you even did that at all
well all right then
I'm still here
okay
okay
where are you okay it's gonna be like a
village version of it
yes
it isn't right hmm
find the purifying Crystal
damn that's a
Lush bamboo
so loud
Miranda's research claims that the mega
mice preserves the memories of people
who passed away within its area of
influence absorbing them into its own
vast Consciousness we also know based on
the previous encounters with the mold
that people who are contaminated with
the mutomycet are connected in a kind of
mold Network I've forgotten this I'm
actually very glad this is here been a
minute since uh the game came out
um if we extrapolate from this we can
summarize the subjects with a strong
Affinity to the Muse of my seat
should be able to use the network to
connect the memories of the Dead within
the mega my seat that's cool it should
be possible to verify this area using
the lab's mega my seat sample we
collected 16 years ago we just need a
suitable subject with a proven
connection to the moment that's me
unfortunately this presents a problem
our organization's policies prevent us
from directly contacting civilians who
are infected with mutomycet certainly
the ethical reasoning is understandable
but it has rendered the confirmation of
this Theory impossible pains me to think
of how much mankind could stand a
benefit from this preservation and
indexing of human consciousness the
possibilities of preserving or even
reclaiming great minds perhaps there's
some way of coming through the red tape
it me I'm that I think
wait
what
the third person is very cool
happy to be doing it
we like literally right back in the
castle immediately
seems Focus
which way to go
this is too many Pathways and now I'm
stressed
oh that's where I came from okay
right yeah okay
um I I do feel like down is Maybe
right option and then
I have to go up anyway okay
okay oh my God there's too many doors
oh that's six six shoes man
anything noteworthy
no sir
hello
what is this I love it greetings
let me out
somebody in that in here
seems like a bad idea about okay it is
some
whatever you want
hang tight I'm gonna see if I can find a
key
it's gonna work in our favorite favorite
to be honest but all right
I don't even have a weapon yet so surely
there's not gonna be
foreign
I got so hopeful about the light source
oh
oh boy I'm just I'm just the bravest
to create art simply add to the rabbit's
Caucasus Decay is not an issue now it
Spruce them up with a bit of makeup
makes them seem more alive
yeah that's okay
maybe we just check this out first
foreign
okay
that's enough of that
it does feel really good to be oh it
says rose on it
that's interesting
that's
my name
it does feel good to be back in this
this um this world and
I know this is supposed to like wrap up
the Winter's story
in a way they didn't give Rose her own
like full game
and I wonder what the next game will be
huh new enemy
the hell is this stuff
chase me no okay
Jesus
oh god oh it's everywhere oh gosh
yeah I guess I can't walk through it
it'll probably eat meat oh wow it's
deteriorated quickly
well I guess I'm sort of inside of the
use of my seat
technically
hey it's def it's safe out here now
you'll be fine
the Dan gotta
says
okay
stop
thanks
thank you that wasn't
whoa cool
just like me
who are you
I'm Rose
what's going on here
just keep moving
I'm already very interested in the story
too dangerous here
oh does that mean the plot that I came
from is blocked off damn it
it
is
at least I think that's where I came
from that's a shame
again I if if you're new here I'm really
bad at direction do I have a map
me too
also okay I don't have anything to panic
about meet up everything is blue
are you going
nice
two
okay I'm good crisis about it I don't
care anymore
foreign
hey wait where are you going
okay
I was gonna say I don't know that we
should trust her if I've ever won
anything from video games it's that you
probably shouldn't trust the dog version
of yourself but
there's also no other way to go so
it'll do
this is cool
ah
there are more than yeah look just like
me
do you know what's happening here
hey are you listening to me come on
okay I need to open the cake
cool
I'm sure I can fix that for you need to
find that handle quickly go deeper all
right
a little deeper it is
oh did I just circle back around
I did okay so probably not that probably
wasn't deeper
sweet
directions man
I mean
the blood path is probably where it
wants me to go
okay cool
something in here
yes great
somebody screaming always a good sign
oh [ __ ]
So Many Bodies
this is a great opening what are we 15
minutes in yeah I'm like already like
super interested
very good walk
isn't that really oh okay oh God
sorry about that
hope you're all right
minor flesh wound
okay
what
[Music]
laughs
it's like a Demento
oh God
[Music]
new enemies
oh that's right I forgot that she has
powers I was like I don't have a gun
I want to have resource Management's
gonna work
[ __ ] you're everywhere
let's go baby
yeah
[ __ ]
get out of here dude oh my God it's the
slowest gate known to man
oh my God it's so slow
God okay
no way
dead end
no stay back
thank you
whatever
this is not feeling great for her
real disaster from the jump
he's helping me
[Music]
oh my God there's no way this is gonna
end well surely you're not surely not
just a pleasant little
crawl space
I don't buy it for a second
it's
fine
what
is that K what are you somehow
uh maybe not okay
what were those things
what is happening here
how what is this
my
not until I get this out of my body
there's a crystal here that will remove
the mold I need to find it
and I'm not leaving until I do
who are you my guardian angel
it's actually very death Loop do
you hear an angel then
Gabriel Michael
okay
Michael
what now
did that
okay type right up
well it I think it wanted me to go that
way right
but I'm so curious
foreign
anything super well because the
Interiors are all very similar but I'd
recognize the layout I think
it is a grand honor that you would
bestow upon me such an important task I
can report the liquid void you provided
has some Splendid properties its most
obvious uses for my dogs on their hunt
to eating them as they pursue our Quarry
it also does wonders for slowing down
and curling the rabbits some have even
been foolish enough to stumble into it
and been completely engulfed oh that's
what's in the basement
with this I'm certain I will be able to
refill
fulfill your expectations and get you
the results you so desire
very polite
okay where are we moving to mysterious
text
pretty standard
these poor things
was he
is that the emotion I forgotten his name
was he the one writing the letters
[Laughter]
I remember this room
uh
[Applause]
he's evil man looks like we caught
another
Lively now aren't you you should have
put that effort into running
it would have made the chase that much
more thrilling
scale of that's really cool
it would seem this little rabbit lacks
the necessary footage
oh my God
you had shown a little grit and actually
escaped that purifying Crystal would now
be yours hmm you're Crystal
who's this
oh now we have a new little rabbit to
pursue
of course yeah Lady D can't be your
older sisters because the timeline right
it makes sense that he has to be there
he's with better than just a quote to me
it's like we're gonna see more of lady
she but she's dead
so probably not
okay
oh no
the voice is really funny
I am remembering this part of the castle
back
[Music]
thank God but we are
[ __ ] what now okay that's not great
um all right okay okay we're back I
guess
well yeah
it is the Resident Evil way seriously
foreign
what like
all right
thank you
foreign
[Music]
how many times how many times
oh God too close
[Applause]
what happened to that face
nollie
oh there we go okay I hate that I wasted
that bullet but it happens
um do I need to use Health now
there's something in this room no uh why
I'm forgetting all the controls yeah my
[ __ ] that's that that was a bit of a
waste but it's okay it happens in panic
that's right there's something in this
room
there's hey gun ammo in this room
so he just lives in this house
killing girls who look like me
foreign
but go off
the disciples await their masks bronze
silver gold with their God or wait
the light should be released
okay
what about if I do well
no who cares it's fine
I guess I should just use the save slots
I always have this debate it's a total
struggle or like I should use them
they're there why would I not use them
I definitely remember this room spent a
lot of time in here
takino
oh that would give me a shotgun
okay
huh thank you
I want to go outside
oh it's locked well never mind we need
both guys
okay
more of you huh
foreign
happened
probably not right
now I'm here
no no I have to go that way
[Music]
oh now it does
foreign
the whole way
in the hallway
great
I think I should go downstairs
I go down here
great I don't want to so I'm actually
very glad that it said I got
to do that at all
that's it
why is music
if you really want to help you could
back me up against those things
or just give me the shotgun
what so I'm on my own
thanks
oh
also yeah don't I have powers
it seems strange to know that I have
them and to complain about them but not
use them but I guess
not yet
should I shoot it
I'm going to okay
just better to you know better to try it
out
then not
oh
hmm
break a core core
you mean that gross lumpy thing
how am I supposed to break it
there we go powers
I literally came here to get rid of them
okay fine but how what am I supposed to
do
what's that hmm
I'm like weirdly like
nostalgic about being back here it is
really nice it's like
the time here you know it's
it's familiar
my friends are all dead but
that's all right
cage
that's cool
also this looks really good right
I don't know that it looks better than
the original game did but I feel like
the lighting is really nice
every time it's so sad
cool thank you
how weird
I'm gonna need three eyes you're gonna
get through there
or maybe not
maybe it's just a locked door
music
wait is this different what was this
always like this I don't remember
like I feel like you used to do that
from the same menu but I could I just
could be completely misremembering
oh
well I already did it why do you
want me to do it again
we're good
I'm so good about going in any direction
to be honest
I think cool
ah
[Music]
two
Oh I thought you were dead
fine please and where'd the other one go
where have you gone they hide behind
Corners you cheeky [ __ ]
that I didn't get too close I guess I
should be running away more [ __ ]
foreign
[Applause]
to be honest
[Music]
not again
the fact that they hide
a little [ __ ] but then they run but then
they run that's good to them
no leave me alone
really hard to shoot you when you're
running right at me oh but I don't know
where he's gonna hide now
you have to come through this way right
[Applause]
it's not looking great
thank you
so I guess running is always an option
it's
been too long since I played
Resident Evil
no
and I said absolutely not no
oh this is the that clock puzzle no way
I'm waiting to do that
I got you no worries
this is probably not the way to go
though because doesn't this lead outside
I think it does just lead back out
Suppose there could be an amplifier up
here whatever that is going to be
yeah yeah yeah yeah
not a single herb
could also use more ammo I recognize
that it is my own fault that I am in
this position but I'm very nervous
and you make mistakes when you're
nervous
you know
I've missed something
what is it
I just have like
like Collectibles like the [ __ ]
gemstones and the walls and [ __ ]
really nothing down here
it's red I can always come back a little
bit
cool amplifier bro
can tell you about herbs I found a means
of dramatically destabilizing parts of
the mutomyc network by introducing a
disruptive Force to block the auto
inducers they use for communication for
example the hard packed cause of mold
known as sclerosis
begin to break down on a cellular level
and disintegrate when thus destructed
sclerodiform when the mutomycin develops
in new locations serving as a sort of
Anchor Point or foothold they are often
associated with a patch of liquid void
through which the mold has spread when
the auto induces of the sclerota are
disrupted it begins to break down any
liquid void connected to the sclerota
will also disintegrate it would appear
that destabilizing this sclerota sends a
signal indicating that location is no
longer viable for mucine habitation
triggering a full-scale retreat oh
that's cool so we can basically like
just clear areas out entirely
don't mind if I do thank you appreciate
it hang on am I not then
I made it where did it go
did I not make it
maybe I didn't
because I don't have any kids
okay
all righty
what's this
so what am I supposed to do with this
thing
Focus
all right
I
feel
different
somehow
all right let's see if this works
but I got
stop telling me to
um okay we have to go back
nothing here
ah thank you
okay it does
it's a bit of a waste though I probably
could have waited until I was in a red
whatever
a lot of mistakes being made out here
what is it
Focus here
that's neat oh that's what it is
beautiful
nope
there's more though that that's just
cool it's cool I like it
that work in the way that I thought it
would
the thing it's formed is dead yeah
that's that's great for me
there's another one
well the music thinks I'm in combat
although I am not
you love to see it sorry do you have to
watch that but I can't help it
I think I missed one collectible in the
entirety of
my Rea playthrough and it still holds me
I it was like one of the final rooms you
couldn't go back it was in uh
heisenbergs
yeah yeah yeah yeah
what's going on out here
town
am I
correct in thinking because I thought
that I saw this before
that um the castle has like some sort of
like a dome over it
it has like a shield of some kind right
you can see that like
kind of um transparent well very
transparent I don't know
um
liquid wool type thing I wonder if
that's I guess I'm not really here
I'm
in probably like in a recreation of it
really sure I don't I don't think I've
been transported I can't get around it
to get rid of it
oh good I love
too far away
okay
get a bit closer
that would get me really bad asthma
being in this room that's a lot of dust
particles my friend
too dark I can't even see it where is it
where the [ __ ] is it
oh it's outside
hello
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh why did my aim get so bad I do feel
like the control sensitivity is off but
also I'm exceptionally nervous today
because it's been so long since I played
a scary game and I realized that when I
started playing I was like oh
oh no I'm not prepared
just doing my best
I think that doing that makes me safe
but I'm actually not sure that that's
correct
great
Rich shut
I wonder if this is going to have um
a
Merchant
of some kind
nice
all right we gotta go back out this way
it's the only way to go
yes
I can't see it for me can I is that some
kind of puzzle
no man okay
keep going
I do think the mechanic's kind of cool
it's not that it's like fun to do it's
obviously very basic you just hold a
button
pretty slow but that's obviously to
allow for combat
um
but actually having rooms change
on the walk back through them is kind of
neat
and yeah obviously opens up different
Pathways as a result which is cool
I'm doing so bad with ammo Jesus
unhinged I I wonder if it's gonna kill
this one somewhere
so cool somewhere
it doesn't appear to be maybe they don't
show up everywhere
there wasn't anything else over here
okay I guess it was just the way through
here
alrighty
foreign
[Music]
that's the way back down I think you
know
you've gotta have you got a core
anywhere bud
my gross friend no
thank you again appreciate it
you have to go down
well I think I think that first one was
the Bronze one
it should be like right there
the courtyard
it's almost bigger than the others so I
don't know
ammo okay
oh
don't have any more kemploy do I
hmm
that's why this silver one is
that is maybe near like where the
elevated her to go outside is
all right there's one first
foreign
look at us a video gaming
I finally got it
um I don't want to see if I
can't go back I can't take this can I
oh
wait wait what binocular door deep in
the basement
to be fair it's not that I thought it
would work
all right basement it is
can I get rid of any more
I don't think I can
what if I do this one
thank you very much
I
I've made too many handgun mistakes it's
my own fault if I have no health I get
what I deserve
rest
what
the thing
I don't know if this was supposed to
happen
I can't the reason it hasn't changed I
need that Crystal
thank you
oh bless you my brother in Christ
thank you for that
I would like to go put this one on
so let's do that put the first one on
I don't know which one it'll fit on but
it's gonna be one of them
okay well I guess it's the the last one
remaining should have checked it's the
the one with the one
beautiful look at us go
is there a typewriter did there is oh I
guess this is now a safe place
cool
um I think I should probably leave it
there everybody while I would love to
continue playing
um
I'm very into this it's definitely mole
Resident Evil Village obviously it feels
very very similar to Resident Evil
Village
um not in any way that I'm currently
finding negative the new ability doesn't
add a ton
um but there could be much more where
that came from I'm not actually sure yet
I'm interested in what's going on I'm
interested in the text on the wall oh my
God sorry I keep popping and um
it's nice to be back here so
yeah I think like they said I think this
is four or five hours long I'm not
positive
um I will definitely finish it I'm
having a good time so far
but yeah seems like a good place to end
it because we we got our first mask and
we're at
almost an hour so thank you all for
watching I will probably stream more of
the game on Twitch
um which means it'll end up on my
channel where I upload my twitch streams
which I'll leave a link in the
description below I have a channel for
that uh now that I'm back I'll start
streaming a little bit more again too
otherwise I will also have some more
spooky gameplay up on Halloween I have
the next episode of the dark pictures
Anthology for you all so I'll put that
up on Monday and uh play which listen is
back this week my weekly gaming news
show is back this week so everything's
like full steam ahead uh thank you for
watching I'll see you guys next time bye